وفي جديد حادثه التفجير خطوط انابيب نوت
ستريم مفاجات باتت اصابعه الاتهام تتجه
نحو اوكرانيا بعد ان كانت تشير الى روسيا
وذلك حسب تقييم لوكاله الاستخبارات
المركزيه الامريكيه تم الكشف عنه قبل نحو
اسبوع هذه الاتهامات لاوكرانيا قد تصبح
عاملا رئيسيا في اجراءات التحكيم التي
تقدر بمليارات الدولارات والتي رفعتها
شركات الطاقه الاوروبيه ضد شركه الغاز
الروسيه العملاقه حيث زعمت شركات اوروبيه
ان فشل شركه
متعاقد عليها في الغاز الطبيعي منذ الصيف
الماضي تسبب في اضرار كبيره بالطبع لها من
خلال اجبارها على شراء غاز اغلى بكثير من
الصوف لكن خبراء القانون والمحللين يقولون
ان الانفجارات التي جعلت خطوط الانابيب
غير صالحه للعمل يمكن ان تساعد في تعزيز
قضيه جازبروم خاصه اذا ثبت ان جماعه
مواليه لاوكرانيا وليست دوله الروسيه هي
التي تقف ورائها ومع ذلك فالقضيه ليست
مباشره لان غاسب روم خفضت التدفقات الخاصه
بها قبل الانفجارات التي جعلت خطوط
الانابيب في النهايه غير قابله للتشغيل